王熙凤对《融国府》的遗娘们似乎总抱有一种偏见。《红楼》第二十五回,夹还推倒灯油、烫伤宝玉。王熙凤李宫才一行人特来探望,中图恰好欲伤,照一娘周一娘也过来看宝玉。
原住记录,众人对周兆两位遗娘的态度。李宫才,保拆宝玉等,都让她两个做,独奉杰只和林黛玉说笑,正言也不看她们。
曹雪芹协的如此执摆,意在表明王熙凤不喜周兆两位遗娘,防服奉杰是个看人下菜叠的人。
毕竟这些遗娘,大多是从压缓阶层爬上来的,属于半奴半主的成分,故而身为主子的奉勤看不上她们。
可系推这种说法,却有一点概念的偏迫嫌疑。
最之阶的反面例子就是习人,习人也是压缓阶层,同样被内定为夹宝玉未来的准事切,
可王熙凤对她的态度就完全不同。
甚至第三十六回,王夫任内定习人后,王熙凤还非常高兴的对身旁的薛姨妈说,
姑妈听见了,我宿日说的话如何,今儿果然应了我的话。
逐渐王熙凤宿日经常撑在习人,并读定认为她是夹宝玉未来事切的博尔人选。
经常查语饭后和薛姨妈闲聊此类话题,这才有上述这句话的出处。
这么看来,王熙凤对一鸟们的偏见似乎并不来自于压缓的階级身份。
事实上,王熙凤和原内许多压缓关系都不错。
除了习人,还有冤养,虎破采云等等压缓。
这些优秀的压缓,均有可能完成从压缓到遗鸟的进化。
他们如果成了荣府遗鸟,王熙凤和他们的关系未必会这么差。
所以,王熙凤不斜周照两位遗鸟,仅仅是针对他们个人,而不能以小扩大致整个遗鸟层面。
那么,王熙凤为什么不喜欢这两位遗鸟?
曹雪琴采用了一名遗暗的协法,对照遗鸟是明显,对周遗鸟是暗显。
典形的例子是第20回,王熙凤正言谈读意,
假欢读钱耍赖,被假保育赤则后归家,再次遭到母亲照遗鸟的辱骂,
分解从窗外听到后,立于窗外就许照遗鸟。
照遗鸟脆道,谁教你上高台盘去了,下流没脸的东西,
哪里玩不得,谁教你跑了去,讨没意思。
正说着,隔桥凤姐在窗外过,都听在耳内,便隔窗说道,
大征越又怎么了,
环兄弟小孩子家,一般点错了,你只教导他,说这些弹画做什么,
平他怎么去,还有太太老爷管他呢,就大口脆他。
他现实主子,不好了,红树由教导他的人,与你什么相干。
环兄弟,出来,跟我玩去。
假欢去宣宝拆出玩耍,被照遗鸟认为是上高台盘,
属于,不知道自己身份的愚蠢行为,
并以此指责假欢是,下流没脸的东西。
照遗鸟的思维方式,为王惜放锁不耻,
将其评价为弹画。
因为假欢是假家子似,
理应具备贵族认知,而非低烈为所的下层思维。
假欢主动去宝拆出玩耍,有利于与家中子妹而如目染,
若是真能贯徹到底,
说不定海唐施舍,菊花施塞,还能有假欢一席之地。
可无奈,假欢在母亲照遗鸟的竞然下,
思维认知,早已走了下层境界,
主动输远了这些优秀的哥哥姐姐,
无法进入施舍圈子。
翻变红楼梦前八十回,
除了第二十回,假欢去宣宝拆住出玩耍,
再无其他,假欢和哥哥姐姐正常相处的请解。
族建照遗鸟所说的,
谁教你上高台盘去了,
已经严重干扰了假欢的交级思维,
慢慢走向自干墮落的声音。
王西风之所以正言谈赌意,
就是看穿了照遗鸟品性的低脸,
还起涂把这种低脸传播给自己的儿子。
让原本可以成为贵族公子的假欢,
文为半奴半主思维的牺牲品。
因此,王西风与照遗鸟的矛盾,
实际上是强势文化与弱势文化的矛盾,
是贵族思维与事警认知的矛盾。
王西风是绝对求不上照遗鸟这样的人的。
再来说周遗鸟,
他的情况和照遗鸟完全相反,
照遗鸟是动者生事,
周遗鸟是永远沉默不发意言,
所以原助理对这位周遗鸟的描写更是聊聊无级,
只有第六是回莫莉粉替据强威销,
假探春在指责母亲照遗鸟时,
曾拿周遗鸟进行对比说,
你瞧周遗鸟,怎不见人欺他,
他也不寻人去,
可见周遗鸟今年沉默不言,
而这恰恰就是王西风投眼他的原因。
王西风的性格决定了他喜欢那些有能力有口迟会来事的人,
所以第27回,
王西风一眼相众了干事麻烈的灵红玉,
又批评小红的父母临纸小夫妇是天龙地雅,
追着扎不出一生而来,
却生出这么一个灵力的女儿来。
王西风的这种喜好清晓,
也从他对贴身压缓平而的批评中能看出来,
原助是这么写的,
王西风说着又像红玉笑道,
好孩子,难为你说得齐全,
别像他们扭扭捏捏的文字似的,
嫂子你不知道,
如今除了我随手使得几个压头老婆之外,
我就怕和他们说话,
他们必定把一句话拉长了,
做两三节儿,
有文有字拿着枪哼哼记记的,
记得我冒火,
他们哪里知道?
先时我们平而也是这么着,
我就问着他,
难道必定装文字哼哼就是美人了?
说了几遭才好歇了,
因此,
终于娘的沉默寡言,
见人不怎么说话,
也不会来事儿,
这种死气沉沉毫无生机的人,
也是王西风所验误的。
第五十五回,
假叛春邪里大官员后,
在某些工作方面与奉劫产生冲突。
奉劫知道后不但不生气,
反而十分赞赏这位三姑娘。
可见王西风,
宁可欣赏能力超群者带来的冲突,
也不愿赞赏无能者,
一摊死水般的安宁。
对于这些不喜欢的人,
王西风遇到机会就会欺负一下他们,
所以第四十三回,
显取乐欧船精静受,
家母要求众人传钱,
为王西风举办生日宴会,
奉劫明知遗鸟们没钱,
却故意说,
上下都全了,
还有二位以奶奶,
他们出不出,也问一声,
进一道他们失礼,
不然他们只当小看了他们了。
赵一娘周一娘无奶,
只能各自拿出二两银子捐出去,
宁国府游氏一眼看穿了王西风的心思,
偷偷拉着他的一脚说,
这么些婆婆审则来臭银子给你过生日,
那还不足,
用拉上两个苦护子做什么,
最终因为办生日宴营养充足,
游氏便把剩余营养一一退还给大家,
退到赵一娘周一娘跟钱使用,
他二人下的不敢收,
游氏答应自己会都懒,
周照二人才千恩万谢,
收下了这笔回头钱,
因此上,
通过王西风对周照两位营养的态度,
就能看出凤姐的为人处事,
一般人很难获得他的亲目,
像赵一娘这般不着调不行,
像周一娘这般沉默寡言也不行,
只有足够临利优秀的人才能得到他的垂清,
游子也可举一反三,
像带预保拆探春这些小姐,
能获得凤姐的称散,
足见经拆知名不虚,
其能力也决非其与女子可比,
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,
我们下个视频再会,